I consider myself to be a very rational
and scientifically minded human being
and as a result I find myself believing
in some scientific theories that when I
say them out loud kind of make me sound
like I'm insane all right I'm gonna try
and convince you that in our own
universe there is a person identical to
you watching a YouTube video identical
to this one on a planet and in a solar
system that is exactly the same as the
one that we are in and that there is not
only one of these carbon copies but
there are an infinite number of them
throughout our universe do I have your
attention okay let's do this
firstly an example imagine a man who has
a hundred different shirts 250 different
ties and just two pairs of trousers
leaving him with a possible 50,000
different unique outfit combinations
most people have them in clothes he is
unique he's exceptional he is our
example he's example man he wears all
the clothes however if we were to
imagine that example man were immortal
and that he never bought any other
clothes in his life we can accept I
think that eventually he would have to
start repeating his outfit combinations
airing that example in mind here is
where things start to go completely
bonkers me and you and everything in our
entire universe is made up of a
combination of different types of
particles and the particular
combinations of all of these different
particles can make up anything from the
simplest hydrogen gases floating around
the universe
to the incredibly complicated
neurological systems that make up our
brains and our memories and in turn us
as individuals that is what science
tells us that sheer number of possible
combinations that these particles can
make is so big that I am NOT going to
bother trying to figure out what that
number is however because there are only
a certain number of different types of
particles that means that the number of
different combinations those particles
can make is finite
meaning the just like example man if you
give the universe enough space it will
have to start repeating itself and it
just so happens that the prevailing
scientific theory at the moment is that
the universe is infinitely big so if
that's true then that means that the
universe
has to have repeated itself which means
that there has to be an infinite number
of different copies of me and of you and
of our planet scattered throughout the
cosmos please believe me when I say that
I know how absurd this idea sounds but I
also know that it comes from a place of
observing our universe and making a
logical conclusion about it it is not
fanciful thinking it is rational
thinking it just it just doesn't feel
like it should be true now obviously
when it comes to science how we feel
about an idea has absolutely zero impact
on how true it is or isn't but for me
personally I kind of like the idea of
infinite Charlie's and I will explain
why what the theory dictates is that not
only are there an infinite number of
identical versions of us scattered
around the universe but also that there
are an infinite number of ever so
slightly different versions of us
scattered throughout the universe and so
for me personally when I'm going about
my day to day life and I make a decision
that I regret or I find myself missing
an opportunity I fail to tell a girl
that I like her or something then what I
like to think about is that somewhere
out there in the universe there is a
Charlie who did tell that girl that he
liked it and not only is there one of
them but there are an infinite number of
Charlie's that made the decision that I
was hoping to make and for some reason
that just makes me feel better so there
you go that's how my brain works
hopefully you found that as interesting
as I think it is and that you don't
think I'm too crazy quick update my
second short film is now in the can and
I'm hoping to have a version of it or at
least a scene of it or something to show
at VidCon this year so you gonna VidCon
look out for that okay you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool